plus vite plus vite et plus vite voilà
le mot d'ordre de qui est prononcé hier
lors d'une réunion de l'OTAN à Bucarest
le ministre des Affaires étrangères rue
Ukrainiens a demandé l'accélération des
livraisons d'armes notamment de défense
aériennes et d'équipements électriques
en appel déjà entendu par les États-Unis
l'Allemagne ou encore la France qui
accorde un prêt de 100 millions d'euros
acquiesv c'était et bien elle est
cruciale notamment pour faire face à la
destruction des infrastructures
énergétiques détruites à 30% par les
bombardements russes selon Kiev on fait
le point sur le terrain à mikolaïve dans
le sud du pays c'est là que se trouve
l'envoyé spécial de France 24 Pauline
Godard
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer la
situation et compliquée il fait froid
très froid très humide il a même
commencé à neiger tout est fait ici pour
économiser un maximum d'électricité les
habitants n'ont pas assez à
l'électricité durant toute la journée et
puis ici la nuit tombe très tôt on la
constaté des hier soir dès 16h la nuit
commence à tomber et mikolaïve est très
rapidement plongé dans le noir il n'y a
pas d'éclairage public toujours dans ce
souci et bien d'économie d'énergie il y
a aussi un autre problème ici et bien
c'est l'accès à l'eau courante depuis
environ la mi-avril il y a très très peu
d'eau douce ici alors les autorités ont
pour le moment tenté on va dire de
trouver du système D le système D et
bien ça a été de raccorder les
canalisations en tout cas un maximum de
canalisations et bien l'estuaire qui se
trouve juste derrière moi le problème
est bien c'est que l'eau qui sort du
robinet quand vous ouvrez votre robinet
est bien la plupart du temps c'est de
l'eau sal ou de l'eau boueuse c'est une
eau qui est corrosive qui abîme les
canalisations et c'est ici un très gros
problème puisque plus de 240 km de
conduite d'eau doivent être remplacés
ici à mikolife ce qui n'empêche pas
malgré tout un certain habitants qui
avaient fui la ville qui était il y a
encore plusieurs semaines encore
énormément bombardé et qu'il est moins
depuis la libération de rerson qui se
trouve la ville de rerson qui se trouve
un peu plus au sud et bien les habitants
commencent ici à revenir malgré ces
conditions qui sont de plus en plus
compliquées ici bonjour Pauline
conditions extrêmement difficiles donc
pour ces
Ukrainiens que font les autorités pour
tenter d'améliorer leur situation
alors vous l'avez dit les autorités
ukrainiennes et bien appel à l'aide
notamment les Occidentaux plus vite plus
vite plus vite plus vite pour des
livraisons notamment de générateurs les
initiatives se multiplient les
Ukrainiens ont besoin de générateurs ont
besoin de matériel pour rapidement
réparer et bien tout ce qui concerne les
infrastructures énergétiques les réseaux
à haute tension la France est en train
d'envoyer une centaine de générateurs
l'Allemagne en a promis plus de 350
l'Union européenne a demandé de son côté
d'actionner le mécanisme de protection
civile pour livrer environ 500
générateurs à l'Ukraine ainsi que 2000
tentes adaptées aux conditions
hivernales et puis Anthony blinken a
fait une annonce mardi une annonce d'une
nouvelle enveloppe de 53 milliards de
millions de dollars qui s'ajoutent à une
autre enveloppe de 55 millions de
dollars qui avaient été déjà débloqué
pour l'achat de générateur je vous
rappelle que depuis environ début
octobre la Russie a engagé
des frappes systématiques sur les
infrastructures énergétiques pour
décourager un maximum les
Ukrainiens selon les chiffres donnés par
le gouvernement ukrainien 25 à 30% des
infrastructures énergétiques de
l'Ukraine ont été endommagés